basically what happens in in the US is I
think that the healthcare system is for
a lot of people no longer sustainable
which means that if they need the help
of the Healthcare System they're often
not able to afford it yeah and when they
cannot help it they are often going
bankrupt it's I think the leading course
cause of personal bankruptcy in the US
is the Healthcare System
yeah and that would not be necessary
it's not because people are consuming
more and more medical services and are
achieving a much much longer Life as a
result that's not actually the story
that is happening because you can
compare to other countries and life
expectancy in the US is currently not
increasing and it's not as high as in
all the other industrialized countries
so some industrialized countries are
doing better with a much cheaper
Healthcare System and what you can see
is for instance administrative load the
uh healthcare system has maybe to some
degree deliberately set up is a job
placement program to allow people to
continue living in middle class
existence despite not having useful and
use case in productivity so they are
being paid to push paper around and the
number of Administrators in the
healthcare system has been increasing
much faster than the number of
practitioners and this is something that
you have to pay for right and also the
revenues that are being generated in the
healthcare system are already relatively
large and somebody has to pay for them
and the result why they are so large is
because Market mechanisms are not
working right the FDA is largely not
protecting people from malpractice of
healthcare providers the FDA is
protecting Healthcare Providers from
competition right okay so this is a
thing that it has to do with values and
this is not because people are malicious
on all levels it's because they are not
incentivized to act on a greater whole
on this idea that you treat somebody who
comes to you as a patient like you would
treat a family member yeah yeah but yeah
but we're trying I mean you're
highlighting a lot of the flaws of the
different institutions the systems we're
operating under but I think there's a
continued throughout history mechanism
design of trying to design incentives in
such a way that these systems behave
better and better and better I mean it's
a very difficult thing to operate a
society of hundreds of millions of
people effectively with yeah so do we
live in a society that is ever correct
observed that our models of what we are
doing are predictive of the future and
when they are not we improve them are
our laws uh adjudicated with classes
that you put into every law what is
meant to be achieved by that law and the
law will be automatically repealed if
it's not achieving that right if you are
optimizing your own laws if you're
writing your own source code you
probably make an estimate of what is
this thing that's currently wrong in my
life what is it that I should change
about my own policies what is the
expected outcome and if that outcome
does manifest I will change the policy
back right or I will change it into
something different I'll be doing this
on a societal level I think so I think I
think it's easy to sort of highlight the
I think we're doing it in the way that
uh like I operate my current life I
didn't sleep much last night uh you
would say that Lex the way you need to
operate your life is you need to always
get sleep the fact that you didn't sleep
last night is is totally the wrong way
to operate in your your life like you
should have gotten all your [ __ ] done in
time and gotten to sleep because sleep
is very important for health and you're
highlighting look this person is not
sleeping look the the medical the Health
Care system is operating poor but the
point is that we just it seems like this
is the way especially in the capital
Society we operate we keep running into
trouble in last minute we we try to get
our our way out through Innovation and
it seems to work you you have a lot of
people that ultimately are trying to
build a better world and and get
urgency about them when it's the problem
becomes more and more imminent and
that's the way this operates but if you
look at the the the the history the the
long Mark of History it seems like that
operating on deadlines
produces progress and builds better and
better systems you probably agree with
me that the US should have engaged in
mass production in January 2020 and that
we should have shut down the airports
early on and that we should have made it
mandatory that the people that work in
Nursery homes uh of living on campus
rather than living at home and then
coming in and infecting people in the
nursing homes that had no immune
response to covet and uh that is
something that was I think visible back
then the correct decisions haven't been
made
we would have the same situation again
how do we know that these wrong
decisions are not being made again if
the people that made their decisions to
not protect the nursing homes being
punished
as I have the people that made the wrong
decisions with respect to testing that
prevented the development of testing by
startup companies and the importing of
tests from countries that already had
them have these people been held
responsible yeah well first of all so
what do you what do you want to like uh
put before the firing squad I think they
are no just make sure that this doesn't
happen again no but it's not that yes
they're being held responsible by many
voices by people being frustrated
there's new leaders being born now
they're going to see Rise To The Top in
10 years and this moves slower than
there's obviously a lot of uh older
incompetence and bureaucracy and these
systems move slowly they move you know
like science one Death at a time so like
yes I think the the pain has been felt
in the previous year is reverberating
throughout the world maybe I'm getting
old I suspect that every generation in
the US after the war has lost plot even
more I don't see this development the
War World War II Yeah so basically there
was a time when uh we were modernist and
then this modernist time uh the U.S felt
actively threatened by the things that
happened in the world the US was worried
about possibility of failure
and this imminence of possible failure
led to decisions right there was a time
when the government would listen to
physicists about how to do things yeah
and the physicists were actually
concerned about what the government
should be doing so they would be writing
letters to the government and so for
instance the decision for the Manhattan
Project was something that was driven in
a conversation between physicists and
the government and don't think that the
discussion would take place today I I
disagree I think if the virus was much
deadlier we would see a very different
response I think the virus was not
sufficiently deadly and instead because
it wasn't very deadly what happened is
uh the the current system started to
politicize it the mask this is what I
realized with masks early on they were
not very quickly became not as a
solution but they became a thing that
politicians used to divide the country
so that that same things happen with
vaccine same thing so like nobody's
really the people weren't talking about
solutions to this problem because I
don't think the problem was bad enough
when you talk about the world the War I
think what I think our lives are too
comfortable
I think in the in the developed World
things are too good and we're not faced
severe dangers
one the danger the severe dangers
existential threats are faced that's
when we step up and a small scale in a
large scale now I don't
I that's sort of my argument here but I
did think the virus is I was hoping that
it was actually sufficially uh dangerous
for us to step up because especially in
the early days it was unclear it still
is unclear because of mutations
how bad it might be right and so I
thought we would step up and uh
even so the masks point is is uh is a
tricky one because to me the
manufacturer of masks isn't isn't even
the problem I'm still to this day and I
was involved with with a bunch of this
work have not seen good signs done on
whether masks work or not
like there still has not been a
large-scale study to me that should be
there should be large-scale studies on
every possible solution like aggressive
in the same way that the vaccine
development was aggressive there should
be masks which test what kind of tests
work really well uh what kind of uh like
even the question of how the virus
spreads
there should be aggressive studies on
that to understand I'm still as far as
far as I know there's still a lot of
uncertainty about that nobody wants to
see this as an engineering problem that
needs to be solved it's it's uh that I
was surprised about but I would find
that our views are largely convergent
but not completely so I agree with the
thing that uh because our society in
some sense perceives itself as too big
to fail right and uh the virus did not
alert people to the fact that we are
facing possible failure uh that
basically put us into the postmodernist
mode and I don't mean in a philosophical
sense but in a societal sense the
difference between a postmodern society
and the modern society is that the
modernist Society has to deal with the
ground tools and the postmodernist
society has to deal with appearances
polit politics becomes a performance and
the performance is done for an audience
and the organized audience is the media
and the media evaluates itself via other
media right so you have an audience of
critics that evaluate themselves and I
don't think it's so much the failure of
the politicians because to get in power
and to stay in power you need to be able
to deal with the published opinion well
I think it goes into in Cycles because
the what's going to happen is all of the
small business owners all the people who
truly are suffering and will suffer more
because the effects of the closure the
economy and the lack of solutions to the
virus they're going to a prize and
hopefully mean this is this is where
charismatic leaders can get the the
world in trouble but hopefully will
elect great leaders
that will break through this
postmodernist idea of uh of uh the media
and the perception and the drama on
Twitter and all that kind of stuff but
you know this can go either way yeah
when the Weimar Republic was unable to
deal with the economic crisis that
Germany was facing
there was an option to go back
but there were people which thought
let's get back to a constitutional
monarchy and let's get this this to work
because democracy doesn't work
and eventually uh there was no way back
where people decided there was no way
back they needed to go forward and the
only options for going forward was to
become a stalinist communist basically
um in option to completely expropriate
um the factories and so on and
nationalized them and to reorganize uh
Germany and communist terms and Ally
itself with Stalin and Fascism and both
options were obviously very bad
and the one that the Germans picked led
to catastrophe that was uh that
devastated Europe
and I'm not sure if the US has an immune
response against that I think that the
far right is currently very weak in the
US but this can easily change